welcome to part 4 of the dev bytes
series making apps beautiful thus far
we've managed to make our app look
beautiful on modern phones and tablets
but we haven't really looked at the
performance aspect having a beautiful
app is more than just how it looks when
it's not moving or animating it's about
making sure it's about also making sure
that it's smooth and jank free so from a
performance tuning point of view what
I'd like to do is profile my device on
the lowest common denominator which is
exactly what we're going to do today
we're going to use the Nexus S running
Android 2.3 fondly known as Gingerbread
so let's see let's switch over to our
Nexus S and see what our app looks like
in its current state Bom Bom it crashed
now we're going to switch back to the
slides and see why the reality of it is
is that we're loading these
high-resolution meet images and then
displaying them as some nails so we're
actually exhausting the memory on the
Nexus S much sooner than we would on our
more modern devices and it would have
even happened with those ones if we had
more images so let's now switch to the
code and see how we can better optimize
this what we're going to do is load
these images in that at the resolution
that we're going to display them rather
than the resolution that they their
source resolution so we use this bitmap
factory options object and we then set
this in just the code bounds to true
what that does is that it makes sure
that the code resources only looks at
the metadata of that bitmap and in this
case the resolution so once we've loaded
that we're going to go into our own
method called calculate in sample size
we're going to try and calculate what
the value of this should be basically in
sample size is a is a value that's used
like a power of two so in sample size of
one we'll mean we load the image in its
native resolution or source resolution
- will mean it'll be halved horizontally
and hard vertically so it'll be a
quarter of the size of the original
image so we just basically use some
basic arithmetics here to work out based
on the source resolution of the image
versus the display or required
resolution and then based on that ratio
we we return this in sample size from
this method so scrolling back up we've
calculated our insamplesize passed it to
our bitmap factory options we then need
to remember to set in just decoded
bounce to false and then go ahead and
load the bitmap with our options so now
that we've optimized it and we're
loading these bitmaps in the the
resolution that we need them in let's go
see what it looks like on the Nexus S
shouldn't crash this time there we go it
launched and we can see the apps running
but it's not running great as we scroll
here you can see that we're getting some
jitter and jank so let's look at how we
can optimize this and let's switch over
to our slides once again the reason that
we're getting this jank is that we're
loading those images in the main thread
in the UI thread and we really shouldn't
do that we should be doing these in a
background thread an hour an hour friend
the async task object class is going to
help us so let's switch over to some
code again and we'll see here we've got
an async task for loading our bitmap we
actually passed the image view to this
to this pacing task and we store it as a
weak reference so that if the framework
needs to free that image view we're not
going to hold on to and we're going to
allow it to be garbage collected anyway
it's going to the doing background
method on our async task this is
happening in a background thread so
we'll go ahead and actually load our
sampled bitmap and this is that code
that we saw earlier so it will kick in
with those optimizations once this is
done in onpostexecute we're just going
to go ahead and apply the bitmap so now
let's see how the app looks like when we
run it on an XSS
great we can see here that as we scroll
the images get loaded in now because
we're doing it in the background what
happens is that we get this placeholder
we're just using a white it's just a
empty image there until the image loads
but it's happening in the background and
the important thing is that our
scrolling is now smooth but we have a
new problem now every time an image goes
off the screen
we're actually relinquishing that image
we're freeing it and then loading it
back in that's not a very good thing to
do so what we're going to look at is how
to fix that so switching back to the
slides what we're going to do is we're
going to use an image cache now what an
image cache does is hold on to the
images so we'll load the image and then
we'll throw it into the image cache and
it'll hold on to the images for as long
as it can and then when we go to request
an image we're going to look in the
image cache first so let's switch over
to code and in the oncreate method of
our fragment what we're going to do is
initialize our LRU cache that's the
image cache we're going to use but for
the cache size what we're going to do is
we're going to set the cache size based
on the maximum available memory on the
device for our app in kilobytes so
dividing it by 1,024 but we're actually
going to get 1/8 of that that that size
so our K should be 1/8 of the available
memory in kilobytes and that's what we
will use to initialize our LRU cache
also keep in mind that we're overriding
the the sizeof method so that we can
tell the cache how big our bitmaps are
going to be that's it
with that let's see what our next
success looks like now so we're going to
launch it we expect it to be nice and
smooth which it is and what we're seeing
here is that as the images go off the
screen they're not actually being
relinquished out cache is kicking in of
course if we blew our memory limit it
would start to dispose and throw away of
those images and
the most necessary but we don't need to
in this situation so we've reached the
end of this devbyte let's switch over to
the slides let's this is where we
started on the left hand side with a an
outdated looking at it now looks
beautiful and modern on modern devices
it runs really well but one thing we
haven't looked at yet is how to make it
look equally beautiful on all the
devices and we're going to do that in
the next episode